[Music]
forty miles southwest of Tucson between
Arizona's ko bokja very mountains is an
Old West Ranch town like no other couch
on key laka was built by this man at
keylock oh that's Edward gabion key
lacquer all with his bare hands
that's right like any old West Ham couch
I'm Tiago has a church a bank cemetery
and it's a loom but unlike most other
Old West town this cow town is still
standing
all because of the smash got drank to
get up here's everything here everything
you see right here we've done a small
trick I had never seen you that figure
how to do it even that water tower that
one there
how lever hiccup check why exactly did
Edward J BT Locker built his own town
and one to a black mother and white
father was orphaned at a young age Jim
Crow America
my childhood was rough always
light-skinned red hair green eyes I
remember a young skier climb the tree
runs you come over here look up and look
up here I'm up here and he urinated in
my face and those are the kind of things
that you have to live with as you could
look like me these hardships he like o
developed an independent frontier spirit
when you say to it I paddle my own canoe
like they say in a way saddle my own
Bronx I wrote it out ident out of this
with this lesson in mind ed constructed
an Old West utopia four decades later
cotton continues a celebration of
individuality with the biannual event
known as kilo Cody's people like to come
to Cal tags
no I should hear no racism except you
who you uh you can dream of things that
never were sure why not
that's the way I my mind thing a lot of
people thought I was crazy I suppose
maybe I am me Ram I'm here Pam
[Music]
you know it's so funny I get this
question all the time do you still
remember how it felt to drown it was the
crippling feeling I was suffocating
under water now I've made it my job to
conquer my fear and to help to get these
kids swim lessons and learn how to
expect the walk my name is Colin Jones I
was in the Olympics in 2008 and 2012 and
I love to get some weapons Coen Jones is
a four-time Olympic medallist swimmer
for Team USA right after getting the
gold medal in 2008 they put the drowning
rates in front of me and I learned that
70% of African Americans nearly 60% of
Latin Americans you know the 40% of
Caucasians feel not afraid so it's a big
problem all over the US I think the
reason that you don't see as many
African Americans in swimming is because
there's such a stigma that black people
don't flip and this is something that
you grow in because you're losing
children you're losing adult and it's
something that can be changed by someone
I want you guys
some lessons are so important to kids to
me personally because I was almost one
of those kids and part of the statistic
when Cohen was just five years old he
almost drowned on a water slide in the
mutant park they had to come out and
grab me and resuscitate me because I was
underwater for about 30 seconds and I
think what's important about the story
is that ultimately supervised I mean it
was that easy and that quick for me to
go underwater that could have been my
last day on this earth and with that
near-death experience colin has made it
his platform to bring water safety
education to kids from all backgrounds
the way that I'm trying to change my
community is definitely with working
with the lake splash initiative I knew
this is my way of giving back to the
sport so it's giving me so much once you
learn how to swim it's like riding a
bike you never forget to take the time
to learn how to fire station big red
truck flashing sirens that cool shiny
pole well it all dates back to colonial
time and this guy had a little something
to do with it that's right Ben Franklin
most known for the Constitution
electricity and the bifocals Ben
Franklin had a weird obsession with fire
safety on a trip to Massachusetts
Franklin notice that the good people of
Boston were much more spire savvy than
his fellow citizens in Philadelphia hmm
this got Ben's thinking and he came up
with the idea to create a club or
society of active men belonging to each
fire engine whose business is to attend
all fires with it whenever they happen
then Ben got weird he wrote an anonymous
letter to his own newspaper as a senior
citizen entitled protections of towns
from fire give Pennsylvania Gazette the
letter encouraged a better fire safety
plan and painted a horrifying
alternative people jumping out of
windows breaking their necks and being
burned alive but it worked
in 1736 the first American volunteer
fire department was born the Union Fire
Company it was comprised of 30
volunteers and you might know some of
them
George Washington Thomas Jefferson and
Samuel Adams that's right our founding
fathers were also firefighters soon
after fire companies and clubs sprang up
all over Philadelphia and then across
the 13 colonies so thanks to the
matchless leadership of Benjamin
Franklin
we now have fire fighters thanks Ben
you chew
Anya's no garnish our gimmick our
support our own Java Dima and Joseph
Samira Varma poppin pills until Magento
mera naam the Giga me class does near
illumine 59
[Music]
they're gonna be cute larger that's
Whitney production services ratiza
[Music]
morning everybody to go Mullen one
wannabe say when you go Samardzija is an
instantly human and 1/4 moment ABBA
ya know America sorrow sorrow vitamin E
sorrow lamentation eora must be dead
people a dissident water source or 11 to
malai have time for summer ml or that
huge hitter football helena bonham alarm
Munfordville body body can happen in my
water I heal a failure in salida mas
know as malice 150 watt inverter anemic
Varma is a guy deontological over a low
vegan Thomas on Oh m'god forces a linear
elastic romantic and English thousand
anybody for servitude and say we for no
thermalize Jerry algorithmic or normal
diet with her bersama
pistol greatness that is called logic
Anna Anna porn even live Raghavan more
eternity together my dignity
Mulligan IRA we will memorize any so
whether - sheikh abu kabra
duty Tejano Kalani did over summer
gorilla City for know for tourism
another many sahaja yoga
Munna balls varam na Cola e7 a medal
Rasta in terrassa Sabatini follow
Bugaboo yoga ba la villita elusive
element as mobile palagi who for know
Polynesia and could arrange a bonus
however many muscles to sell mobilizing
my
um what a cool
[Music]